some protesters burned bins and clashed
with police in Paris during a
demonstration that was otherwise
peaceful thousands of students and
public sector workers once again in the
street angry with French president
Emmanuel macro's pension reform and his
government's decision to force it
through Parliament by decree
maybe the government is finally starting
to hear that many French people are
against this reform and against macron
for not listening
the reform raises the retirement age
from 62 to 64 which we don't want and
forcing it through Parliament proves
that there is no more democracy in
France
protesters want the government to scrap
the reform that macro says the changes
are necessary to sustain the country's
pension system for future Generations
Nationwide strike since the beginning of
now it's hard to see how the deadlock
between the trade unions who are leading
the protests and the French government
will end
one of France's main Trade union leaders
says it's time for mediation
they need to suspend raising the
retirement age to 64. that's what angers
people most then over the next month or
so we should appoint mediators so
everyone can say what they want a plan
swiftly rejected by the government
we can talk to each other directly the
president has already said is ready to
receive the unions once the
Constitutional courts approve the new
law macro could sign the bill into law
within weeks reforming the pension
system was one of his campaign promises
but the changes have come at a cost as
anger against them isn't subsiding
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Paris